متسوله وابنتها جذتان هاميدتان في منزلهما
[موسيقى]
الحكايه بدات عندما لاحظ اهالي المنير
الغربيه في امبابه غياب متسوله وابنتها عن
الانظار لمده ثم انبعاث رائحه كريهه من
منزلهما ما اثر استغرابا دفع الجيران
للتواصل مع الابن وعند وصوله تفاجا الابن
بجثه والدته وشقيقته لتبدا رحله البحث عن
الجاني الذي ذبحت ضحيتين بغرض السرقه
التحقيقات اوضحت ان القاتل جزار كان
يستاجر شقه بعقار ملك للضحيتين الاولى 80
عاما وابنتها 55 عاما وذلك بعدما افادت
احدى الجارات للمباحث بانها شاهدت القاتل
عند نزوله من مسكن الضحيه قبل عده ايام
[موسيقى]
الجامع اعترف بفعلته والقي القبض عليه
بالاسكندريه بعد هروبه من محل اقامته
الحاليه اما الصاعقه فكانت انه لم يعثر
سوى على 900 جنيه بعد نحر الضحيتين فقرر
سرقه تقمشوك وملاعق وسطانات غاز منزليه
لكن التحقيقات دلت على ان المتهم لم يرى
مبلغ بليون جنيه ومجوهرات كانت في الشقه
فالمتسوله تمتلك العقار الذي تقطنه هو
ثلاث عقارات اخرى ولديها اموال سائله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]